- [Instructor] Let's say
someone walks up to you
on the street, and they
give you this expression.
X squared plus 7x plus
10 divided by x plus two.
And they say, see if you
can simplify this thing.
And so, pause this video
and see if you can do that.
And one way to think about it is,
what is x squared plus 7x
plus 10 divided by x plus two,
what is that going to be?
All right now, there's two ways
that you could approach this.
One way is to try to factor the numerator
and see if it has a factor
that is common to the denominator.
So let's try to do that.
So we've done this many, many times.
If this looks new to you,
I encourage you to review
factoring polynomials
other places on Kahn Academy.
But what two numbers add up to seven,
and when you multiply em, you get 10?
Well, that would be two and five.
So we could rewrite that numerator
as x plus two times x plus five.
And then of course,
the denominator, you
still have x plus two.
And then we clearly see
we have a common factor.
And so as long as x does
not equal negative two,
because if x equals negative two,
this whole expression is undefined,
because then you get a
zero in the denominator.
So as long as x does
not equal negative two,
well then, we can divide the numerator
and the denominator by x plus two.
Once again, the reason why
I put that constraint is
that we can't divide the
numerator and the denominator
by zero.
So for any other values of x,
this x plus two will be non zero,
and we could divide the numerator
and the denominator by that,
and they would cancel out,
and we would just be
left with x plus five.
So another way to think
about it is this expression,
our original expression,
could be viewed as
x plus five for any x that
is not equal to negative two.
Now the other way that
we could approach this
is through algebraic long division,
which is very analogous to
the type of long division
that you might remember from,
I believe it was, fourth grade.
So what you do is you say, all right,
I'm gonna divide x plus two
into x squared plus seven x plus 10.
And in this technique, you look
at the highest degree terms.
So then, you have an x there
and an x squared there.
And say, how many times
does x go into x squared?
Well it goes x times.
Now you'd write that in this column,
because x is just x to the first power.
You could view this as
the first degree column.
It's analogous to the place values
that we talk about when
we first learn numbers,
or how we group or about place value.
But here you could view
it as degree places
or something like that.
And then you take that x
and you multiply it times
this entire expression.
So x times two is 2x.
Put that in the first degree column.
X times x is x squared.
And then what we wanna do
is we wanna subtract
these things in yellow
from what we originally had in blue.
So we could do it this way.
And then we will be left
with 7x minus 2x is 5x.
And then x squared minus
x squared is just a zero.
And then we can bring down this plus 10.
And once again, we look at
the highest degree term.
X goes into 5x five times.
That's a zero degree.
It's a constant, so I'll write
it in the constant column.
Five times two is 10.
Five times x is five.
And then I'll subtract these
from what we have up here.
And notice, we have no remainder.
And what's interesting about
algebraic long division,
and we'll probably see it
in another video or two,
you can actually have a remainder.
So those are going to be situations where
just a factoring technique
alone would not have worked.
In this situation, this
model would have been easier,
but this is another way to think about it.
You can say, hey, look,
x plus two times x plus five
is going to be equal to this.
Now, if you wanted to
rewrite this expression
the way we did here, and say, hey,
this expression is equal to x plus five,
we would have to constrain the domain.
You'd say, hey, for all x's
not equaling negative two
for these to be completely
identical expressions.